[Music]
so
[Music]
gilberto rodriguez and miguel and
rodriguez
were the heads of a cartel that was
totally different than the other cartels
they looked at it more as a business to
expand
and they were involved in the cost
versus profit
you have to learn who your enemy is
otherwise you're not going to win the
fight
[Music]
and i studied all over a long period of
time the rodrigo solas
and they were very smart strategic
thinkers
who were always one step ahead of the
game
gilberto and miguel rodriguez have a
piece of several hotels
and on cali's largest shopping center
and
[Music]
so they were to be respected yes they
were dopers and traffickers but you
cannot underestimate them you
underestimate people of that caliber
you're doomed
my name is willian rodriguez i'm the son
and nephew of the
colleague cartel founders miguel and
gilberto rodriguez
there was a strategic alliance between
my dad my
uncle and his koa
they had different ways to see how we
should fight this war against
authorities escoward wanted to do it
through violence
we wanted to do it by corruption
my dad miguel was called el senor to
serve
my uncle gilberto built an economic
empire
he wanted to fulfill his dream my dad
because
he wanted my dad to be a lawyer and
that's why i wanted to be a lawyer i
want to be like my dad i wanted to
help my family
people think that bandits don't have
values but my dad uncle did
their honor violence was the last step
to resolve the problems because
dead people don't pay what they owe
[Music]
gilberto and miguel rodriguez are
forcing modern business methods on a
violent trade
[Music]
the cartel forced its employees to fill
out this application
form cartel hopefuls had to enter the
names
and addresses of their entire family
they had to know who your family members
were where were they what did they own
didn't own cars planes automobiles
trains anything they had to know all
about you
before you were trusted into the system
the mobinoku came they did by different
ways first they did it into little
planes into the caribbean and
in central america then they shipped
into doing it to mexico to handle the
ever larger
shipments of cocaine heading to the
united states
the cartel used container ships
sometimes even loading up entire
passenger jets
it is a marriage of convenience between
colombia's cali cartel
and the italian mafia when the cold war
ended
a new war began the problem of cocaine
in russia began only one or two years
ago
cocaine is a new problem for us
from moscow to madrid
[Music]
from rome to tokyo
the kali cartel is creating new markets
[Music]
in raw profit it now outstrips boeing
texaco
and pepsi they had so much power
in those moments they thought they were
in the top of the world
they were planning to eventually become
the kennedys of colombia
in the anarchos cassettes you can see
the power that
miguel gilberto had because this guy is
saying you have
the future of colombia in your hands if
you give this money you have a present
[Music]
you